いイェイい
年度末にバシッとキメましょう！
はじめしゃちょー質問コーナー！！
お待たせしました~！！
ヴォォエッッ
wwwww
やるよ
はい、というわけでこのたくさんの質問、リクエストありがとうございました！
今回はツイッターで募集したということで、
ハァ・・・
本当にたくさんの方々がツイッターではじめしゃちょー謝肉祭でつぶやいてくださいました。
ありがとうございます！
ハァ・・・ハァ・・・
募集動画出してから３月の１５日までだったので、
その期間の中でコメントを採用させていただきました！
約！！
８０個です！！
マジ超大変...　んぁ
ありがとうございます！
や、　あの正直言うと　すごい
大変でした
マジでコメントめっちゃ見たからね
２日間くらいマジでかかったんですけど
というわけではじめしゃちょーの質問コーナー
さっそくやっていきましょう
ではいこう！
やめんわ　やめとけ
バン！
〈チャカン〉
う！
♪～
痛！
アッいった！
まって!
まって
頭蓋骨バーン
わかりません
違います
どれ
♪～
はは
ちょっと面白い
あのこれよく来るんですけども
Twitterで僕にこのリプライを送ってくれる割合の
たぶん８割強くらいは女子です
・・・・・
うふ
動画を見てるのは男子のほうが多いんですけど
基本的にTwitterとかは女子のほうがはるかに多いんで
そうなってしまいます
男子もよかったらTwitterでからんできてね
～♪
はあ　はらいた
おまえら
おまえら　こんなことしちゃだめだ
おぉヴっ
まずい
しなきゃ
命を大事に！
《はじめは体が硬くて
ブリッジをする力が
なかった》
文字数が足りねえ！
いにしえの精霊よ我が魂を導け
今ぞここに帰らん
光のイグゾーストバースト
ヴァンヴァンヴァンヴァンヴァン（銃声音）
闇を制するのは光ではない
同じく闇だ
カオスエクスプローション
・・・　《♪～
俺２３歳だった
結構自信あるんですけど
♪～
ﾋｬｸﾅﾅｼﾞｭｳﾖｳﾞｫｫｫｫｫﾝｯｯ！（１７４）
なにやらせて
あっもしもしトミックさんですか
《ああ久しぶり》
お疲れ様です
《どうしたの？》
すみませんちょっと　今ちょっと訳あって
《うん》
ちょっと警察に捕まっちゃったんですよ
《交通違反みたいな？》
まあちょっといろいろやらかしちゃて
《あーーー》
どうすればいいですか
結構重い罪なんですよ
《なにやったの》
ちょとなんか凄い万引きを
《何凄い万引きって？》
どうすればいいですか
《どうすればいい？・・・どうすればいい？》
《それUUUMに言ったの？》
あ一応言いました　社長にも言いました
《ホントに？なんだって？》
いや　とりあえず罪をつぐなえって
《何なの罪をつぐなえって？》
いやもうホントにこればかりはどうしようもないからみたいな
《え初犯でしょ？》
はい
すみませんトミックさん（呼びかけ）
《何？》
すいませんウソです
《ばかやろう》
ｗｗｗ
《ええ　そうです　ここは　はじめしゃちょー　謝肉祭です》
そりゃやべえよ
へー
多くね！
バァン！
おゆまるぅうううう！
あ
ぜんぜん大丈夫だ
バッットブンHelloYouTube！
ぷるるるるるるる
ぱしゅー
でんちー
≪Ye~~~~~~~ah≫
これマジ
怒られそうだからやりたくねぇんだよ
いやいやもうね個人ＬＩＮＥしてくるあたりで結構脈ありだと思います
普通だったらだよ
インフルになります
バイトの時に「大丈夫？」って普通聞くと思うんですけども
個人ＬＩＮＥ聞いてねわざわざ心配してくれる時点で
もーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
わかんないですけど
きっといいイメージだと思います
がんばって下さい
うぁ
フォンニチハ
ハジメシャチョーーーデス
おれさーよく
なにさせてる！
ズルズルズルズル
んごんご
♪～～
やっぱそうっすよね
今後気を付けます
ごめん
何言ってるかわかんない
はい
うわーーーーーーーー
ふっ
これで満足かぁ？
な
な　何なんだよお前ら
うんこうんこって
そんなにうんこしたいとこ見たいのかよ
よく考えろよ
YouTubeでうんこした動画出したら
消されちまうだろ
するけどさ
ああもう何なんだよ
どんだけ俺にバク転させたいんだよ
俺とバク転に何の関連性があるんだよ
ううううう・・・
いやこっちはしねえよ？
はっ
《銃声音》
お兄ちゃんお兄ちゃん　犯罪係数はからせて
《犯罪係数over４００》
♪～
《セーフティーを解除します》
うわーーーーー《バーン》
おぇ
はっ
はい
泣き声《シャリ》
なにをさせたいのぉ？
プリン
おい
♪～
よく　作ったな
この画像
いけてるぜ
うわはぁ～（あくび）
キャーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
♪～
うふん
ガタンゴトン　ガタンゴトン
あ　すいません
くっそ
はっはっはんｗｗｗ
三次元が好きすぎる人っていうのは実際いますし
僕だとちょっともーそうなんだなって思っちゃいますね
僕はあの追わないタイプなんで
諦めたくないんだったら
思いは伝えたほうがいいと思います
がんばれ　三次元の良さ見せつけてやろうぜ
ごめんね　こんな髪型で
ふん　うぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ　はぁーー
はは
完全におちょくってるだろ
ありがとうございます
というわけでこれくらいにしておきましょう
はい　というわけでいかがだったでしょうか
かなり質問の量多くしてみたんですけども
ホントに全部見てんの？とか全部見れてないでしょみたいなやつがすごい多かったんで
できる限りマジで見てるんで
今度質問するときはね、ちゃんとしたコメントとかリクエストとかをちゃんとしてくれれば僕は嬉しいです
ハイというわけでいかがだったでしょうかはじめの質問コーナー
はい　という
はい
♪～